[موسيقى]
ديسمبر 2022
ندخل مدينه بخموت اعنف وانشط الجبهات في
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
الى جزئين
القوات الاوكرانيه تتمثل في الجزء الغربي
اما القوه الروسيه فنجحت في الدخول الى
الضواحي شرقا حيث المواجهات بالاسلحه
الخفيفه القصف المدفعي لا يتوقف ليل نهار
فار
[موسيقى]
الجنود الاوكراني
المعلومات سريه
تطلق النار عليهم وهم يردون دفعناه من
الوراء قليلا
حركه هي ماساه هي موت ثمنها حياه شخص مات
مستقبله ومستقبل عائلته
اوكرانيا
هذا المبنى يستخدم لاجلاء الجنود المصابين
في الصفوف الاولى
200 300 متر على ابعد التقدير
لمهاجمه اسلاميه
بعد اشهر من القتال لم تعد مشاهد الحرب
تشغل المدنيين
ولا يخافون الوضع عادي بالنسبه اليهم
الشوارع خاليه في مدينه سكنها 70 الف شخص
قبل الحرب تحولت كلها الى الساحه معركه
لا اتصالات ولا ماء وكهرباء ولا غاز انا
ونيكولاي واطفالهم الثلاثه يسرعون نحو
مركز للمساعده الانسانيه
لشحن الهواتف والاتصال بالانترنت
والاستراحه دافئه واحاديث مع اخرين
ربنا
لم تصيب شقتنا بل دمرت شقه جيراننا اطفات
انا وزوجي نيران وحدنا مدرستي تهدمت اتعلم
في المدرسه رقم خمسه
انجليزي جيدا انا هناك اوناسا لطيفين
يريدون استقبالنا ومساعدتنا لكن في
النهايه سيجدون انفسهم مثلنا وعندها هم من
سيحتاجوا الى المساعده الان القتال محصور
هنا لكن قد يمتد الى اي مكان اخر
[موسيقى]
المتطوع بخيله لم ينجح في اقناع العائله
بالمغادره
سبورتكاس همم
الاذاعه الروسيه فقط عاشوا لي وقت طويل في
فراغ اخباري الى لهم ان ازواجهم سوف
يجبرون على الالتحاق بالجيش وانهم
سيزينونه قيلت لهم اشياء كثيره
الامر مربع
يطلقون النار علينا تمشي وتسال متى ستسقط
القذيفه تعيش كل يوم كما لو انه الاخير
هذا مخيف تحس بالظلم اريد ان اغادر ليس
لدي ما اقوم به هنا اغادر لكي يستحم بكل
بساطه هذا محرف
كان تسكن قبل ثلاثه ايام اصابت ضربه
للمبنى
هناك
[موسيقى]
لقد سميت اذنيه
لترك منزل العائله
افراد عائلتي انجلينا كانوا في الخارج
عالقين تحت الركاب تم سحب الجثث رجل
واطفاء مات ايضا اعذروني هذا سعد اريد ان
ابكي
[موسيقى]
نتجنب هذا النقاش في العائله
انجلينا اكدت لنا ان والدها متدين للغايه
نتجه هذا الاحد الى الكنيسه الروسيه
الارثوذكسيه لمحاوله لقائه
[موسيقى]
القداس يقام في السرداب على ضوء الشموع
استراليا توشيبا
في قلب المواجهات
هناك
محظوظون لان الانفجار انحرف جانبا
للعيش تحت القصر
كان الامر مخيفا راح البيت يرتد والارضيه
كانت تهتز كالهلام حرفيا كالهلام
الحرب قسمت العائله زوجه الكسندر توجهت مع
حفيدها الى روسيا انجلينا تريد التوجه
غربا للانضمام الى اخيها المناصر
لاوكرانيا وبقي الاب مع ابنه هنا
روسيا ليست سوى بلد واحده وشعب واحد هي
ورده واحده باصان مختلفه
اعتقدوا انها لا تريد رؤيتنا لم يجبرها
احد على المغادره تركتنا بملء ارادتها ولم
يطردها احد
هي لا تحب طريقه عيشنا تريد الحريه
الحريه بمفهومها السيد
تها الجنود يتوارون في خنادق تجهز تحسبا
لاي تقدم روسي
شكرا تعيش عليك ان تحفر كلما حفرت اعمق
كلما ازدادت فرصك بالنجاه
هذه فنادق جديده مازلنا نعمل عليها نحدث
فيها ثغرات كي نتمكن من التصويب في حال
التو زاحفين الينا من هذه الجهه
شرق المدينه
[موسيقى]
تنور الشغل
المخدرات او ان دماغهم مغسول تماما لا
يستسلمون ابدا ولا يمكن ايقافهم هذا مروع
حقيقه يشبهون النسوه
يتحفظ الجيش الاوكراني على تفاصيل خساره
لكن سيارات الاسعاف تنقل المصابين على
مدار الساعه يوزعون على مستشفيات العسكريه
كهذه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اسبوع
خمسه سيارات اسعاف تصل في اقل من ساعه
يقال لنا ان قرابه 100 جريح يستقبلونه هنا
يوميا
لقد تم استهدفهنا
قذيفه مزقت رجلي
هذا ما حدث هذا استطيع نقول رجلي تؤلمني
لكن على ذلك كل شيء بخير
اختباء الجميع
صباح اليوم التالي حان وقت الرحيل بالنسبه
الى انجلينا ومكسيما
من قبل لاحد الاصدقاء
مجانا
[موسيقى]
امس بكيت كثيرا الامر صعب حقا لا رغبت لي
في الرحيل
على بعد 260 كيلو متر غربا هناك ستبدا
انجلينا ومكسيم حياه جديده
على الطريق مبنى اصابته قذيفه منذ قليل
تفكير بان انتظار السلام قد يطول في بخموت